what's interesting is that the way we go
about finding our marriage partners
today's is quite different from the way
it used to be in this culture right when
you look at a dental number of studies
with speed dating and match com and
what's interesting is that you know we
still walk into a speed-dating event
thinking about what it is we were
looking for in a mate right and so you
ask people and like women will say I'm
looking for somebody who's really kind
and sincere and smart and funny and guys
will say looks matter but they'll also
say things like well she should be smart
and kind and you know those are sort of
typical responses and if you give them
just a few options like five or six then
they will rate them on the very
characteristics that they said were
really important to them you know so if
they they said kindness or funniness was
really most important to them than they
will be more likely to say yes to the
person that they thought was kind and
funny now if you expand their choice set
so you give them 20 different speed
dates everything goes out the window
everybody starts choosing in accordance
with looks because that becomes the
easiest criteria by which to weed out
all the options and decide so Who am I
going to say yes to
you